[Music]  thank you  good evening  uh you're gonna be here all night  ready Sue  we've got a spectacular show with some  amazing talents  dad take the kids home and watch out for  Timmy he's a biter I'm not changing any  diapers  the producer said the ratings were  dropping of course they were look at you  guys now ew  I'm the joke always of town  oh Manny you complete me  hey Fury call Judy oh I cannot get the  password  face scan oh nice one  life was hard for small mammals  welcome to zootopia's biggest talent  competition  drop that beat  so I'll just move this table over here  might get a little musky that's fine  the family you have makes you rich the  friends you choose flakes them family  and with these things you will never  feel small  there's the train hey oh embrace your  body and be free  I just saw the one place in a sheep that  has no wool  parents Stream It on Disney Plus  [Music]  thank you  [Music]